that time year it's Comic Con basically
comic-con is where people prepare the
entire year or even the year before to
create the coolest and sexiest costumes
ever to comic-con the past couple of
years and it's so insane there are just
the sexiest nerdy costumes that you will
ever see
sex and Mario's you'll see sexy
transformers you will see sexy anything
I'm not even a dude and I'm just like
last year is the first year that I
actually dressed up but it was so crazy
because I usually just go to comic-con
wearing my normal human costume it was
really fun last year because Stan Lee
created a hardwired character to go with
my AOL show and we created this whole
crazy custom hardwired costume so this
year I was like now what I don't really
have to wear so I'm just gonna wear my
normal human people clothes but
thankfully guys I'm freaking out you
guys remember last year we came out with
a custom iJustine so so happy hoodie and
guess what this year's 2014 I just gene
Comicon hoodie is officially here and no
there's no camo this year I was like man
I really want to do camera but we can't
do camo again so we've got a cheetah
leopard print hood awesomeness I love it
I went with some really bright colors
this time because I thought you know
what like if you're gonna wear one of
these hoodies you want it to be like
hello I am wearing all freakin crazy
hoodie so I'm gonna be doing a meet-up
at the so so happy booth on Saturday
what do my notes say 12 o'clock to 2
o'clock at booth 5 0:37 my first
comic-con outfit is complete it will
have them online where you guys can get
them but if you want to get one first at
comic-con you know where to go booth y 0
through 7 I'll be doing a lot of sapphic
on this year and most of those include
meet and greets so I'm doing another one
with Intel and nerd HQ where you guys
can come they give a costume on bonus
points because we're gonna be doing a
little contest costume costume contest
whoever I think has the best costume I
will post picture of you and me together
on my Instagram and intel will actually
give you a core i7 processor I'm sure
some of you guys would probably rather
have the processor than get a picture
with me but that's totally cool I've
been filming this video I don't have the
in
times yet for the meetup but when I do
get them I will update the description
and be sure to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram because I'll be posting all of
the updated places that you guys can
find me at Comic Con I'm actually really
excited about this so Hot Topic and her
universe is doing a high fashion geek
couture fashion show so I'm gonna be one
of the judges there's 36 designers that
are competing to win a collaboration
with both her universe and Hot Topic so
they'll actually be sold in Hot Topic
stores so I'm one of the judges and even
more exciting than this if you're not
familiar with her universe I am now like
a newfound number-one fan so since I was
doing the judging they're like yeah
we'll send you a couple of the pieces
from the collection awesome okay cool so
the Box Rives everything I will
definitely be wearing this one day at
Comic Con it's like a freakin Star Wars
dress
looks like a nice dress with just a
basic pattern and all the basic pattern
happens to be Marvel characters can
people think I don't actually know about
it's Doctor Who I've never watched any
Doctor Who so that's definitely on my
to-do list they have some super huge
Doctor Who you guys may get the
reference I don't get the reference you
guys wanna go to the Fashion Show it's
on Thursday and it's free admission to
the Comic Con badge again all the
information is in the description so
it's easy for you guys to find last but
not least this month's IG book club I
don't have a book yet to read from
audible so I need a book from you guys
that I can read or have read to me on my
way to Comic Con if you guys want to get
your 30-day free trial and your free
book use audible.com slash iJustine so
thank you guys for always being so
supportive like I love getting your book
suggestions I was actually thinking
about having The Fault in Our Stars be
read to me again cuz it was such a great
book so be sure to leave me some book
suggestions and again I'll become slash
I just seen let me know what book you
guys get I would love hearing your book
suggestions because you guys are so much
cooler than me and you guys know all the
cool things and hopefully I will get to
see you guys at Comic Con because it's
gonna be so much fun and if I don't get
to see you at Comic Con I will be making
vlogs so you'll get to see me at Comic
Con I
Jenna will be there she will be hanging
out she'll be it all of the meetups yeah
I think that's it sorry that was my
voice that was yelling and I was so
excited about my cookie and all of her
universe' okay that's it
I'm gonna go I'll see you later and it
also tracks your sleep but it's so big I
keep hitting myself in the face at night
look the good thing about it is like I
mentioned the heart rate